now all of these examples were accessing
a live site but you can also set up port
forwarding to allow your mobile device
that acts as a local server on your
development machine over USB let's take
a look to do this you want to make sure
you have a server running on your local
development machine in this case I'm
going to use pythons simple HTTP server
on port nine nine nine nine now to
verify that it is actually working I'm
going to access that on the local
machine and it's working fine if I want
to now access that same page on my
mobile device I need to set up port
forwarding I can go back to the chrome
inspect page click on port forwarding
and set up a port forwarding rule in
this case port 9999 on localhost or IP
address one 2700 one I enable port
forwarding and click on done when i
refresh this page you'll see that port
forwarding is now running on port 8080
and 9999 at this point we're all set up
so let's try it out I'll open a new tab
navigate to localhost 9999 on the mobile
device and voila the page is ready to go